[Music]
max
from mexico
[Music]
the help has been invented for centuries
the one that helps before the pizza we
were already doing the help
I am led by manzano and we are on
November 20th and children from the
central oaxaca market we have two classes  of
tortillas that the big one and the girl from bs
to charcoal pack of the flavor because
otherwise they don't know when it's done the help
is thrown first it's the seat it's worth the
bean paste for the quesillo not the
vegetables and then the sauce and the  last comes
the meat and the tasty one
I have been here for 27 years my daughters help me it
is a complete family for
us
juana what years well the help that is the
tradition of oaxaca you already come with 23
chelas well you like natura a little help
from anáhuac medical
worm  in Spanish and it's next time with
me remove the gray
[Music]
and it's the first time you see how
tejate is made it may seem
strange to you but it's a tradition that we've been
carrying on for centuries my name
is abigail e  This is my Sunday grandmother and
together we leave you at calle fresnos
y salsas number 107 santa lucia del
camino oaxaca tejate is a
pre-hispanic and festive drink but
now we drink it every day in the city
tejate is made up of two masses, one
cocoa and one  of corn after these two
masses are mixed by hand then
water is added little by little until
the tejate mass dissolves once
the cocoa flower sprouts it is known that it
leaves it will be ready when I drink the
tejate I can  feel subtle flavors of
cocoa and they remind me of a festival a
culture tradition a origin if you
have never tried tejate you are going to love it
[Music]
lamela is a traditional dish from
oaxaca these memelas can
be found outside of oaxaca but not  they are the
same my name is car at the stand it is
called memelitas doña mari and we are in
oaxaca in the san josé la
noria subdivision the stand has been here for 33 years on the
same corner a memela is a tortilla
d  e corn prepared with a seat that is
the fat of the fried effort meat it
has bean paste sauce and cheese
what makes it special is the sauce that my
grandmother prepares and it is a secret recipe
the first taste when you bite into it memela is the
itching of  salsa you have to know how to
eat it and particularly here you
eat it with your hands but it can't be a
disaster you're hungry and have a jam
[Music
] anyway the wef on the smith shelf in a
small group
look who's coming to oaxaca and I don't try
a red moon snow did not taste the
flavors of oaxaca
my name is paulino gonzález martínez i
am the owner of the
typical queen siboney
ice cream parlor located in the heart of the town of zaachila oaxaca
mexico prickly pear snow is
made precisely from the fruit  from a
wild cactus that is produced in the
Oaxacan Mixteca so that you can make the
tuna ice cream what you are going to do
is remove the pulp from the fruit you
are going to crush it you are going to add the sugar  ry
the water nothing else and you put it to
freeze between what is a
traditional stainless steel carafe and a
wooden barrel and from there you put the
sea salt and the pieces to rotate as
the movement of the solar system is carried out
it's the taste of oaxaca neither more nor less
[Music]